Do: I'm gonna give you guys
a little kind of peek
behind the scenes of what it's
taken to scale YouTube.
Since this is only
a half an hour talk,
I can't really go
into a whole lot of detail.
But this should give you
some idea
of what it takes to provide
one of the largest sites
in the world.
Okay, so the general kind
of layout here
is that I'm gonna talk about
a little historical context,
set things up.
Talk about a few pieces
of our scalability.
Some of the key challenges
we've faced,
lessons we've learned,
and go into Q and A.
This graph is kind of--
this shape of graph appears
very often.
I guess in the context
of this presentation,
it could be a number of things.
It's probably--
it probably corresponds
to the price of a gallon of gas,
but I'm not gonna talk
about that.
Google has great food, so...
I think that was true,
but I'm not gonna talk about it
either.
I'm still scarred by that.
And--but the thing that it does
actually represent
is the daily video views
over our lifespan.
So it's pretty amazing
the growth that we've had.
It's kind of interesting
when you see
at certain points when
we've added machines or whatnot.
We added capacity,
made things faster.
Added some great features.
Then the graph definitely
spikes up a bit.
Okay, so quick timeline
of YouTube.
February 2005,
we were founded.
We received our first round
of VC funding
in October 2005,
eight months later,
so we got our first office.
And one of the more interesting
scalability challenges we had,
or one of the more interesting
engineering challenges we had
was trying to keep our monitors
dry in our new office.
So the first day that
we moved in it started raining,
which is normally fine
when you're in a building.
Except that there were about,
I don't know,
seven or eight different leaks
in various places.
And we had just gotten
our new, nice,
big 24-inch monitors.
And we didn't really want them
to have any kind of issues
with the water, so we--
After--after maybe
20, 30 minutes
of trying various things,
we took the plastic wrapping
from our IKEA furniture.
We fashioned a funnel
out of that,
and we used the rubber trash can
to catch the water.
We had just enough trash cans
and just enough plastic
that we were able to divert
large--large pools of water
into the trash cans.
And I think I--
I think I drove back once
just to make sure
that the trash cans weren't
over-full.
So definitely interesting times
already during that time.
Just about five months later,
we actually hit 30 million
video playbacks per day.
That was only one year
after we were founded.
So pretty amazing numbers.
And I'll go into a little bit
of details,
you know, what it took
to get there.
A few months later,
we more than tripled
that number.
So pretty amazing.
It was kind of interesting.
We'd add, like, 5%--
you know, 5% or 10% capacity
and we'd get as much if not more
traffic gain from that,
so it's kind of interesting.
A few months later
we got acquired by Google.
And my personal favorite part
is we got a lot of free food.
So that made me quite happy.
The crazy thing is that
by the time we were acquired,
we were already a top ten site
by various external measures.
Like, just top ten period
across all websites.
So pretty amazing considering
that we were only maybe about
1 1/2 years old at that time.
We were number four on Alexa
by Q3 2007
and by other measures as well.
And today I think there's
a new updated number now
but last I heard there was
10 hours of video
uploaded per minute.
It might be more like 13 now.
And hundreds of millions
of video playbacks per day.
It's certainly a lot
of playbacks per day.
I can't give the exact number,
but it's--
It's pretty mind-boggling.
So real quickly,
the pre-acquisition team.
We had two sys admins.
Two software guys,
myself included,
making sure that the site's
scaled.
Two feature developers.
Two network engineers.
One DBA.
And unfortunately no chefs.
And now we have two as well.
So I guess the theme
of two continues.
Here's my little algorithm
for handling rapid growth.
You start by identifying
and fixing bottlenecks.
You, uh, drink the beverage
of your choice.
I'm not suggesting anything.
You just, you know, drink
the beverage of your choice.
You sleep a little bit
and you notice something new
and you start all over again.
That's how it is I guess
with a rapidly growing site.
One of the key phrases we had
in the early days
was "these are good problems
to have."
And after a while,
we were, like,
"I'm gonna kill the next person
who says that phrase."
man: Is that multi-threaded?
Do: Well that's a good segue
into my next line.
Because in this particular case,
there is a little bit of
drinking and sleeping
going on there.
This is one of our two
sys admins
before the acquisition.
All right, so to move into some
of the nuts and bolts here,
we have web request flow.
Starts with an end user.
Then the request flows
from the user's browser
to a set of NetScaler
load balancers.
From that it goes
to the web servers.
And this is a bank of web
servers in a YouTube colo.
And these machines don't really
maintain any local state.
They're just, like,
one goes down,
nothing really happens
to the site.
Within these machines,
Apache receives the requests
from the NetScalers.
It checks to see
if it's a dynamic request.
If it's a dynamic request,
it'll will forward the request
on through fast EGI
to a local apserver.
The multi-process apserver
running on the same machine,
which is written in Python,
our programming line nature
of choice
for all the application code
here.
And that--while Python retrieves
information
from various places.
It retrieves information
from RPC,
from our mem cache servers,
which store information
retrieved from databases
and other expensive--relatively
expensive data sources.
And obviously our databases
for things that are either
uncacheable
or are not in our caches.
For video, we have
two different places
where video can come from.
The first is our CDN.
It's an internal project
written by a group at Google.
And that CDN takes care
of a number of things.
It basically takes care
of the content
that is most popular
on the YouTube website.
Sort of the mega-hits
and the things
that may not be necessarily
a hit within the U.S.
but a hit maybe in Europe.
Let's say for example
maybe some, you know,
pretty interesting soccer videos
for example, which may be
more popular in Europe.
It takes care of serving
of all those videos.
It makes sure that there are
multiple copies of the video
for quality of service,
reliability.
And also insures that
a copy of the video
is relatively close
to the user.
So they're not going over
various network hops.
Like too many network hops
and a transatlantic link
to get to the video.
And for the rest of our videos,
they're hosted on--
at YouTube colos
in various places
in the U.S.
At least for right now.
We're considering
other locations,
but for now it's the U.S.
Key technologies.
We use Linux,
specifically the SuSE
distribution of Linux.
Various versions
in the 10.x line.
We use Apache as I mentioned
just recently
for serving of content
through the YouTube.com site,
as well as the mobile site
I think
and some other things
and the API.
And for video serving,
we use lighttpd
because that's just
so much faster
in handling large files.
It just blows Apache away
in terms of performance
when dealing with large numbers
of connections,
high connect rate,
and large numbers of videos.
Or I mean large file size
rather.
MySQL is used for
all the metadata storage.
So things like
user information,
like users--the user name,
hash version of the password,
et cetera.
That kind of thing.
And finally,
as I mentioned Python--
and it turns out that Python
was actually a very good choice
for programming languages
for us
because especially
in the early days
when it was very difficult
for us to recruit people
especially when we were tiny.
We didn't have a full time
recruiter.
It was just far easier
to put out a purchase order
to get, like, ten machines
versus getting, like,
one or two talented engineers
to magically materialize
and start and get ramped up
in our systems.
So we traded off,
sort of timed the market,
and developed our efficiency
for, you know,
for some other stuff.
Maybe slightly lower code,
but code that's less susceptible
to stack overflows
and other nasty things
that you might see
in other programming languages.
And finally Google technologies.
We use a number of things
that you might have read
about and seen.
Obviously Search is one
of the key ones.
Asides from Search,
we use Bigtable internally
for storing video thumbnails.
We use GFS for a number
of internal file storage needs.
We use protobuffers, which
were recently open-sourced.
And just a number of Google
technologies in general.
We're kind of scaling that out
over time
as we find specific problems
that require massive
computing power
and require the distributed
computing
that the Google infrastructure
affords us.
For our databases, we--we--
we started with one
and obviously
like Amy said we started
with one main one
and a replica for backup
and a replica for reporting.
But we quickly outgrew that.
We now have multiple vertical
partitions
which are basically when
we take a part of the website
that kind of stands on its own.
And that part of the website
doesn't have
too many external dependencies.
We took that--
We stuck that part
on a separate set
of database machines
and maybe even a separate set
of web-based machines.
And we said, "Okay,
this can scale on its own.
It doesn't have to bother
the rest of the site."
The same thing with other parts.
For parts of the site
that were sufficiently large
and--and that were hard
to disentangle,
like for example
the user metadata
and the associated video
metadata,
we did horizontal partitioning
where we split it up.
Like we have multiple databases
with the same schema
But different sets of users.
So one nth of our users
are in this partition.
One nth are here,
one nth are here.
And we did that just because
that seemed to be the most
scalable way to do it.
And then we have a look-up
database that allows us
to associate a user
with one of these partitions.
So that common operations
like watching a video
and seeing a user's
channel page
are much quicker than
they would be otherwise.
We had to scan through each
of the databases.
Those scalability challenges--
we've had a number
of major challenges.
It seems like every time
we add capacity,
there's a number of things
that can sap away the capacity.
The first was rapid,
unpredictable growth.
It's pretty amazing,
like as I mentioned before,
when it seems like no matter
how much capacity you add,
the users come back
and consume all of it.
It's gratifying
and it's rewarding,
but at the same time
it's definitely a challenge
because especially
in the early days
we didn't have, you know,
the budget.
You know, pre-acquisition.
And even post-acquisition,
there's still only so much
you can do
when you're building
a certain kind of buffer
and then the growth
just eats through
all that buffer and more.
So it's an interesting game
to play
not having too much excess
machines around.
Not spending too much money
at one time
versus trying to keep up
with user growth.
Passionate users.
We couldn't have foreseen
when we started this site
that some users would have
thousands and thousands
and thousands of videos
and people would want
to do video blogging
for every second of their life.
Things like that.
And those are good uses
of our site.
But it just means that
we need to work
a little bit harder
in some of these cases
to make sure that
we can accommodate
these types of uses.
New features.
A couple years ago,
the video space was brand-new
and you were lucky
to be able to play a video
without installing some kind
of OS specific plugin
or whatever.
But now there's definitely
a higher baseline, right.
I mean, not only
do you need
to have ubiquitous access
to videos,
imbedability, APIs,
all that stuff.
All that stuff is assumed.
Now you get into stuff
like recommendation algorithms
and social graphs
and all sorts of things
that are
not computationally cheap.
So certainly a challenge
to try to balance
user experience, new features,
and scalability of the site.
Pushing hardware
and software boundaries.
I'll talk a little bit
about this later on.
But basically when you run
hardware and software
too close to its limits,
it's more likely to fail.
And I'll go into a couple
of examples
of times we've run
into these kinds of issues.
And finally, performance
bottlenecks are getting obscure.
We file bugs with a couple
of the vendors
that provide support
for our open serve software,
because sometimes we want
a little extra few people
to help look at some issues.
And it turns out
when we forward those bugs
to them, they're, like,
"Really?"
And then they spend a few days
reproducing it.
And then they don't really have
any kind of real solution
for us.
It's kind of interesting
when you get to that level
and when you start Googling
for stuff
and when you start
searching blogs
and you don't find anything
about the problem
you're encountering.
It definitely puts you
in an interesting spot.
And some of these problems
can be solved
by having more headroom.
But for some
of the software stuff,
we're pushing it in ways
that I don't think the creators
ever intended.
So here's one example
of an issue we had.
If you can't read it,
it says, "We can't accept
any more videos.
Too many videos."
So this was sent at 2:24 A.M.
on October 22nd.
I was about to go to sleep
at that point.
And this wasn't a very pleasant
email at that point.
And basically our video uploads
had ground to a halt.
After a little bad debugging,
didn't take very long,
we figured out that well,
we sort of did the original
bone-headed
let's get it out kind of--
start-up kind of mentality
of putting the--
storing the video thumbnails
for each of our videos
into separate subdirectories.
But all the subdirectories were
in one flat directory structure.
So we had tens of thousands
of files in one directory.
Not a good idea.
So we ran into inodes
per our directory limit,
at least on EXT3, which was
the file system we were using.
Pretty bad thing.
It's not something like--
it's obviously
not rocket science
that you shouldn't put
too many files
in a flat directory structure.
But we were trying
to keep up with growth
and it wasn't too hard
to solve it.
We went to, like,
a tree structure.
Hierarchal structure.
It just wasn't the most pleasant
thing to code
at that time of night.
That's all.
And to test
and under the pressure
of all the video uploads
failing in the meantime.
So it wasn't the funnest thing.
Another thing was going back
to the earlier comment I made
about pushing things
to the limits,
we were pushing our database
to its limits
because we hadn't developed
the infrastructure
required to partition it yet.
It's a difficult problem.
So this email, uh--
Or this posting I should say,
this article from CNET
was covering our down time
that we had.
It started at 7:30 A.M.
and went for five hours.
It was very unpleasant.
I think actually more unpleasant
than the actual down time
was the fact that my parents
were calling me
asking me if I was okay.
You know?
Trying to lend me
their moral support.
So I was, like, I just need
to deal with this.
So it's--
We were--we looked at the laws
and MySQL had given us
an error.
The error was that checksum
had failed.
And the reason--
what happens when MySQL
reads data from the disc
is that there
is a checksum stored
for every page,
which is about 16k I think.
Stored on disc.
And when MySQL reads the data
from the disc,
it calculates a new checksum
and compares that
against what's stored
on the disk.
to make sure that nothing
in between
the disc and the process
is messed up
and the data is
actually intact.
Turns out
that they didn't match,
so MySQL kills itself
at that point.
And not only
does it kill itself,
it takes four or five hours,
depending on the volume
of transactions
and how many--
the volume of changes
that have not been
flushed to disc.
It will take four or five hours
to recover.
At that point,
like a lot of us,
we didn't have a dedicated DBA
at that point.
He had just joined.
He didn't know MySQL yet.
And I was filling in for that.
Anyway, we went through
all sorts of stuff
to try to figure out
what the culprit was.
We searched everywhere online.
We found a lot of questions
but no answers.
No solutions to this issue.
And we frantically put
a whole bunch of orders out
for different pieces
of hardware
that may not exhibit
the same issues.
We were thinking maybe
it's a hardware issue
because not everyone
is having this
and lots of people us MySQL.
Some of these people
are bigger than us.
And after a long period of time,
we happened upon one blog post.
Exactly one blog post
written that very day
saying that there is an issue
with this little guy
which I'm sticking on with
an expansion slide.
It's a riser card.
Because we had recently
for performance purposes
switched from a 4U machine,
which is taller,
to a 3U machine because
a 3U machine
could be outfitted with a faster
IO subset stem.
At least for the vendor
we were using.
And the shorter height
meant that
we couldn't accommodate
a full-height expansion card
like the rate controller
that we had.
So we had to put a riser card
so that instead of going
like this,
the card goes like this
where there's plenty of room.
And it turns out that
the combination
of the rate card
and the riser card
would sometimes cause
interesting fluctuations
in voltages that might cause
an inverted bit
every now and then.
So that's exactly what happened.
The data was fine
on the disc.
We validated it after
it crashed.
It was fine.
But somewhere between--
Somewhere in reading the bits
off the disc,
something went wrong.
But that was definitely
a very tense
two or three days--
or weeks rather.
And the last thing--
the next thing I'm gonna mention
is actually one
of my favorite ones.
So we were again
gonna run out of disc space.
We were having vendor issues,
trying to get things in on time.
Growth was just explosive.
So we did the right thing,
which was to order machines
slightly early.
And we said, "Oh,
let's rush the shipment to us."
Problem is that the shipment
was rushed in the wrong way.
It ended up, um--
actually I don't even think
this was the--
this is where it originally was.
I think it ended up
on someone's BMW originally.
Unloaded unceremoniously
on someone's car.
So that was an interesting
thing.
We scrambled.
We worked around this.
But it was not pleasant
when you have 40 machines
costing a couple thousand
dollars apiece
and your lifeline for accepting
more videos
on the concrete,
probably broken.
Okay, so I'm gonna wrap up here.
So basically things that we did
to scale
is we kept our code
very simple.
We made sure that
all the pieces were very simple
so that we can optimize,
so that we can debug issues,
so that we can re-factor.
We iterated on pretty much
everything
that we possibly could've.
Software, database, caching,
et cetera.
We tweaked the patches
configuration file
a number of times.
We tweaked OS buffers.
We even tweaked
our RAID settings
and we use a hybrid
of hardware and software RAID
for our databases.
We tweaked 'em
on a memory in our system.
So pretty much everything.
It was a very iterative process.
The last thing that worked
in our favor
is I think that we just had
a really good team.
I was pretty honored
to be a part of this team.
Had a lot of fun.
This was kind
of a nice experience
where we were celebrating
reaching 100 million
video views per day.
And we decided to grab
some burgers
and this particular restaurant
serves champagne
with their burgers, so...
It's a lot of fun.
All right, so I have
a few more minutes left,
so any questions you guys have?
man: [unintelligible]
Do: EXCUSE ME?
Do: Yeah, and we also hired him
for a little bit too,
so that's fine.
man: How long did it take him
to find out what the riser
problem was?
Do: I think he was--
actually we didn't hire him
for that particular issue.
It turns out that he was helping
another customer.
And he had posted
about the experiences
that he had with
the other customer.
So we forgot to ask him
how long it took
to figure out that issue.
But yeah, it definitely
took a while for us
to settle on that,
'cause we had to swap out
all the RAID cards
in all of our machines,
which is not very fun
when the databases
are actually running.
Yes.
man: Can you speak a bit about
your content conversion?
How you accept content,
approve it, conform it--
Do: Okay, so we accept--
this is somewhat
in flux right now,
but the way that we've been
doing it
since we were pretty much
founded
is that we accept the content
through an htp post
from the web browser
or from API or whatever.
And then from that
we perform a couple of steps.
We do sort of identification
to make sure it's actually
a video, for one thing.
Some people upload
PowerPoint files
and stuff like that.
And we don't support that.
And frame rate detection,
source detection, et cetera.
We do a number of things
like that
and then after that
we put it through transcoding
using the settings we detect.
And then after that we--
we take the transcoded file,
we copy that to the machines
that it's gonna be served from.
And for a couple
of the other formats--
there's H264.
There's a couple other formats
for the mobile phone,
et cetera.
Those happen currently after
the initial FLV encoding
as well as the higher-quality
version.
So that's at a high-level
at least what happens.
Yes.
Mm-hm?
man: Can you put up the Apache
software slide again?
Do: Excuse me, I didn't hear
the question.
man: Can you put back up
the Apache software slide?
Do: Um, let's see here.
This one?
Okay.
Yeah, it's a little bit small,
but I think I spoke
to most of it hopefully.
Yes.
man: Are you sharing
the database at all?
Are you splitting up?
I imagine that you have
ridiculously huge tables
for some of the lengthy users.
You have
a hundred million companies
consuming your stuff,
so they're naturally
very impressed.
Do you have to partition
the databases?
[unintelligible]
Do: Definitely, definitely.
I spoke a little bit
about that
in a previous slide where
we do a combination
of vertical partitioning
for things where the table
is manageable.
The size is manageable.
Maybe the traffic
is quite high.
But for things where
both the size and the traffic
are particularly challenging
to cope with,
we do horizontal partitioning
where we have a set
of master databases
with different sets of data
in each of them.
And each of those have replicas
that we can issue reads
to those in an efficient way.
So that's how we handle it.
And then we have a look-up
database to map
users and videos to each
of those partitions.
Does that answer your question?
man: It does kind of.
I spoke with some people
from High Five
and they were saying
that they actually
wrote it up beyond
that where this table
was broken up further
into different charts.
They were using--
They weren't using MySQL
because MySQL's indexing--
there was too much overhead
for each one of those.
So I was surprised
that you were using MySQL.
But I was curious
how you're dealing
with some of those issues.
Do: I think our usual solution
for all this
is to partition more I think.
That helps a lot,
because we found that database
has a sweet spot.
It's kind of hard to figure out
what that sweet spot is.
I sat through empirical,
like,
actually trying things out.
It turns out that not all
the data has to fit in memory.
Just the data that you need
to use within
a certain period of time.
Like the working set,
in other words.
So we found that the memory
to disc ratio
is probably the key thing
to scale.
And a number of the other--
like the indexing
and all the other stuff
we've tweaked that over time.
Um, one last question, yeah.
man: Did you guys build
on some sort of a tool kit
for that
in order to implement
the scaling of it?
Do: Um, no.
A lot of the stuff
that we've done
is, like, kind of home-grown.
We have a very light layer
on top of the Python DBAPI.
MySQL Python.
And we just build kind of
our initial layer
which is dealing with
a single database.
And then as time went on, we--
what was kind of nice
about Python,
other languages like Python
that are high level,
is that we had this--
we use this thing called
Decorator
around all the functions
that acts as a database.
And all it is
is an intermediary.
It's a proxy to the function.
And that gives you the state
that you need
to talk to the database.
And since we have that layer
of indirection,
we just were able
to plug things in.
And we use a little bit
of Python magic
to make things work seamlessly
so that 99% of our code
didn't have to change,
which is pretty nice.
Okay, I think I'm running out
of time for questions
unfortunately,
but thanks for listening.
[applause]